spacex's Starship the world's largest
rocket was set to fly to space for the
first time last week it didn't get there
everything after clearing the tower was
icing on the cake
most companies wouldn't call a fiery
explosion icing on the cake but for
SpaceX crashes like this
are part of a unique learning process
that CEO Elon Musk expects will one day
bring humans to Mars and help fuel
NASA's ambition to return to the Moon
here's why Starship is so important to
the future of space travel and what the
latest test means for the Rocket's
future
musk has been talking about building a
spaceship to go to Mars for years here
he is in 2016. this is really intended
to carry huge numbers of people
ultimately millions of tons of cargo to
Mars
well that would be both massive and
reusable and would eventually become
and I can't think of anything more
exciting than going out there and being
Among the Stars as a community this is
what we've been working toward in hoping
for this is Mike massimino a former NASA
astronaut who worked on the Hubble Space
Telescope the ability to go and do these
things to go to the Moon to go to Mars
to explore even further this is the kind
of spacecraft that can make that happen
Starship started to take shape in 2019
first came the star Hopper a smaller
craft used to test engines that would be
used on Starship musk unveiled an early
version of the spacecraft in September
that year uh this is this is I think the
the most inspiring thing that I've ever
seen early prototypes of the spacecraft
faced challenges
and in order to be reusable it needed to
be able to land which it couldn't do in
Flight tests in 2020.
but for SpaceX these crashes weren't
necessarily a bad thing they're part of
the trial and error method that SpaceX
regularly uses to test new spacecraft
SpaceX philosophy is more like fail fast
but learn faster NASA is more like we
can't afford to have anything explode
while we're learning we have to we have
to be ready to go it's taxpayers dollars
we got to get it right
on March 3rd 2021 Starship marked a
major accomplishment launching to about
six miles up and making a landing but
the rocket exploded just after the
cameras stopped broadcasting but just a
few months later a prototype landed and
didn't explode
see on the live video we are down the
Starship has landed
Starship has taken on an increasingly
large role at SpaceX and not just
literally it's Central to the company's
future business strategy Executives have
said they want to start launching the
spacecraft regularly with starlink
satellites and it signed a pair of
contracts with NASA to develop a variant
of Starship that would carry astronauts
to the Moon
those deals are worth over four billion
dollars it's certainly what NASA is
counting on that's going to get people
back to the moon and land on the moon so
it's a key piece of what what NASA is
trying to do by 2021 the Rockets design
was coming into Focus
it was made up of two parts the bottom a
226 foot tall booster called super heavy
which was designed to push the 164 foot
tall spacecraft that may one day carry
dozens of passengers out of Earth's
atmosphere
altogether Starship stands at almost 400
feet tall in comparison spacex's next
largest rocket is just 229 feet tall
this is the the biggest rocket
ever made and there's a reason for that
the further you want to go the more
payload you want to take the more things
you want to take the bigger the Rockets
you need by the end of 2022 SpaceX Was
preparing for a key test starship's
first test flight using both parts of
the rocket musk said the year before
that there was a lot of risk associated
with the first launch I would not say
that it is likely to be success
successful but I think we'll make a lot
of progress and he still wasn't
optimistic the day before its initial
scheduled launch this is not like a you
know some sort of train leaving the
station at precisely like you know 903
am or something like that the first
attempt set for April 17th was postponed
due to a frozen valve
then three days later SpaceX was ready
for liftoff
the plan was for Starship to take off
from the launch pad in Texas the booster
would then separate and fall into the
Gulf of Mexico as the spacecraft's
engines fired and took it on a 90-minute
flight then it would come down and crash
in the Pacific Ocean but that's not what
happened shortly after Starship launched
at 9 33 a.m Eastern a graphic on the
live stream indicated that three engines
weren't working with more appearing to
go out before the blast it reached more
than 1 300 miles per hour before it
started to spin yeah it does appear to
be spinning the shuttle that was
intended to separate from the booster
here didn't we should have had
Separation by now obviously this is uh
does not appear to be a nominal
situation
after climbing 24 miles the rocket began
to Tumble back to Earth and around four
minutes into its flight Starship
exploded SpaceX said a flight
termination system was triggered on both
the spacecraft and the booster when you
have a failure you learn a lot from that
failure so I think their plan was to
test to the point of failure and then
let's learn from that what we can from
that failure so it never happens again
minutes after the explosion the company
tweeted that success comes from what we
learn Starship is grounded for now as
the Federal Aviation Administration is
overseeing an investigation into what
happened during the flight an agency
spokesperson said but musk said they'd
be testing again in a couple of months
this is a huge step if they can get this
right if they can figure out how to do
this with with such a big rocket I think
it's going to be not just taking people
to the moon but it's going to help us to
explore the rest of our solar system and
maybe be on someday so I'm very excited
I wish I could go I don't think I'm
going anywhere but I'm really excited
for the people that will be going
yeah
foreign